[Music]
there is a language barrier inside the
walls of our schools and it's not going
away
in fact the volume of students who
arrive in classrooms without the native
language in their toolkit is steadily
increasing in the United States the
number of English language learners in
the nation's Kate weld student
population has more than doubled since
1990 when students aren't able to
comprehend a new language it can be
difficult to socialize with peers or
understand new concepts often these
students feel disconnected from their
school community sometimes despite a
teacher's best efforts to explain
something students with a language
barrier still feel lost with Microsoft
translator teachers can easily engage
students regardless of their language
abilities teachers simply tap to start a
conversation and share the code with
their students students join the
conversation by entering the code into
any device with web capability then they
choose which language they would like to
hear or see as the teacher speaks
translator provides real-time audio in
the chosen language for each student it
also provides a live real-time
transcript of the conversation students
can hear and read the conversation as it
is happening in class the transcript
appears on a student's device in the
language of their choice
in fact Microsoft translator can
translate into multiple languages
simultaneously this live translation
allows students to be fully engaged in
the topics and social dynamics of the
classroom translation can be tricky with
unique names or subject specific
vocabulary but with the PowerPoint
add-in translator reads everything in
the teachers slide deck and slide notes
so it can create a more accurate
translation translator gives me the
opportunity to reach my students in a
way I never could before
I love seeing their faces light up when
they realize they actually understand
the message I'm trying to get across
they can participate in class
discussions like never before
translation doesn't only accommodate
that learning of non-native speakers it
helps other students to taking notes in
class can be a challenge but the
transcripts provided by Microsoft
translator allow all students to access
the conversation after the fact
Microsoft translator allows students to
move from feeling confused to feeling
connected with peers and engaged in
learning translator saves time provides
real-time translation and keep students
captivated with classroom conversations
just visit a kms slash translator edu to
learn more and download the app
[Music]
you